[تصفيق]
في كثير من الاحيان نحاول نساعد الافراد
يتخذوا قرارات
افضل نحاول نوهم لسلوكيات افضل ودائما
نلقى الى ادوات تعودنا عليها كثير منها
على سب المثال الحوافز منها
التعليم نفترض ان الشخص ما يعرف يتخذ قرار
محدد او سلوك محدد لانه ما يعرف كيف بس هذ
الادوات ما دائما تنفع لان التفكير البشري
مختلف خلنا اعطيكم
مثال كثير من المطاعم تحط على قائمه
الطعام تحط عدد السعرات الحراريه على اساس
ان الشخص يشوف عدد السعرات الحراريه
وبالتالي يحاول يتجنب الاكل اللي هو غير
صحي هذه هو الفكره الاساسيه انك تعطي
الشخص معلومه وتتوقع ان الشخص يتصرف على
ضوء هذه المعلومه طبعا اكتشفنا لاحقا ان
هذا غير
صحيح في احدى الدراسات اكتشفوا ان هذا
اصلا ما يغير سلوكيات الافراد ما زالوا
ياكلوا اكل غير صحي طبعا في اسباب مختلفه
منها على سبيل المثال ان الموضوع يبغى له
حسبه في الذهن لازم اعرف كم اكل في اليوم
حسب عمري ذكر او انثى لازم اعرف كم كليت
الصباح كم المفروض اكل الحين وكم يبقي حال
نهايه اليوم وبالتالي فيها حسبه ذهنيه
وبالتالي صعب انك تتخذ ه القرار في كثير
من الاحيان ايش اللي يصير احنا ما نتخذ
القرار اللي احنا فعلا متوقعينه او هو
الانسب النا خلنا اعطيكم مثال ثاني عشان
توضح الصوره واريد رفع ايادي لو
سمحتوا كم واحد منكم هنا يعرف ان الاهتمام
بصحته شيء
ضروري ما شاء الله كل القاعه طيب السؤال
الثاني كم واحد منا يتمرن في اليوم على
الاقل 30 دقيقه يشرب كميه الماي الصحيحه
يتجنب الاكلات الغير
صحيه اقل عن نص
القاعه هذا
تمثيل فكره انه ما شخص ما شرط انك تعطي
الشخص المعلومه ويتصرف على ضوءه احنا نعرف
ايش السلوك الصحيح بس في اشياء ما تخلي
نتصرف بالطريقه اللي احنا نريدها وهذا ما
يسمى
ب الفرق بين النيه والفعل اللي هو انتنن
اكشن جا نعرف السلوك الصحيح نعرف ايش
المفروض نسوي بس ما شرط نسويه الفكره اريد
اوصلها هنا ايش انه طريقه تفكيرنا والعقل
البشري
معقد وبالتالي ايش اللي
يصير ما دائما في التفكير انه 1 ئ 1 يساوي
2 في كثير من الاحيان هذا الشيء
يختلف خليني اعطيكم بعض الحقائق وبعض
المعلومات اللي فعلا شويه تثير الفضول
كثير من الاحيان نحاول نجمع بين شيء
جيد وشيء
سيء ناكل اكل جسم وبعدين ايش نسوي نشرب
شاي
اخضر على اساس الشاي الاخضر هو سائل السحر
اللي يغسل كل شي ونفس الشي نشوف ايش لما
نروح نعمل رياضه لما نطلع من النادي
الرياضي بعد ما نخلص صار عننا تصريح ناكل
اي شي هذا تصرفات غريبه بس هذا واقعيه
اعطيكم مثال اخر في شيء اسمه المحاسبه
الذهنيه احنا كثير من الاحيان اذا حطينا
في بالنا انه مبلغ ينصرف على شيء محدد
خلاص لازم ينصرف هذا الشيء ما نقدر نحوله
الى شيء اخر ابسط مثال في السفر ايش اللي
يصير في اخر يوم في
السفر يكون عندك مبلغ
متبقي طيب ولازم تص بذاك اليوم خلاص اخر
يوم الطياره تنتظر بينما انك تشيل المبلغ
ترجع البيت البلد وتستخدمه في شيء افضل
لكن لا حطيت في ذهنك المبلغ ينصرف ح هذا
الشيء وبالتالي بتصرفه في هذا
الشيء هذا ما يسمى بالمحاسبه
الذهنيه 40% تقريبا من سلوكياتنا في اليوم
عباره عن عادات من يوم تقوم الصباح الحد
ما تنام جزء كبير من الاشياء اللي تسويها
كلها عادات فيها عادات جيده وفيها عادات
سيئه كيف تتشكل هذ كيف تغيرها يعتمد على
نوع العاده والتحدي اللي بتحصله انك كيف
تغير هذه
العاده معلومه
اخرى نتاثر بسلوكيات غيرنا وهذا اعطيكم
مثال صار
اليوم انا لما كنت جاي وقفت في الطابق
الارضي رحت عند المصاعد لقيت ما شاء الله
امه كبيره تنتظر وكل واحد يجي ينتظر معهم
كل واحد يجي ينتظر معهم رغم انه في
درج
الفكره هنا ايش كثير من سلوكيات المجتمع
احنا نتاثر بها ونتبعها نفترض هم يعرفوا
اكثر فش اللي صار هنا شافوا كل حد ينتظر
قالوا هذا هو المكان الوحيد الدرج موجود
بس تاخذ مسار اخر طبعا هذا في شيء ايجابي
في شيء سلبي الشيء الايجابي كثير من
الاحيان انه تنتظر سلوكيات المجتمع ليش
لانها يمكن انت ما تعرف كيف تتصرف ونواجه
هذا كثير كم مره تدخل مكان على س المثال
وما تعرف هل تسلم على كل واحد ولا تسلم من
بعيد ت شوف الشخص اللي قدامك على الافتراض
ان هو فاهم السالفه
طبعا وفي طبعا شيء سلبي اللي هو ايش انه
مرات يكون السلوك اصلا خطا وهذا ما يتعلق
برمي المخلفات على سب المثال او القياده
بتهو بقدر الامكان سلوكيات المجتمع تحدد
سلوكياتنا احنا في
الاساس مثال اخير اللي يتعلق الناس
المهتمين بالاكل في كثير اشياء موجوده في
بيئ تنا وحاول نتاثر مننا بس احنا ما نحس
بها منها على سبيل المثال حجم
الاصن اللي تستخدمها للاكل كل ما كبر
الصحن بتاكل اكثر كل ما اقل الصحن بتاكل
اقل حتى لو صحن كبير وحطيت فيه شويه ما
بتحس بالشبع ليش ما بتحس نفسك انك كليت
كثير لان في مخيلتك انه بعده كان الصحن
فاضي فهذه من الاشياء الغريبه اللي واحد ي
يفكرنا فعلا فيها انه تفكيرنا ما سهل واح
ئد واح ما يساوي ان لما نتكلم عن طريقه
تفكير العقل البشري طيب هل في شي هل في
اطار ممكن يساعدنا كيف نفهم في عده اطر في
عده نماذج خلنا نعرق على نموذ نين عشان
نفهم بالضبط كيف الواحد يفكر
فعل واحد من نماذج التفكير او نماذج
السلوكيات اللي هو ما يسمى
ببيجي فوق
وهو من كتاب عادات صغيره يقوللك ان اي
سلوك في المجتمع او اي سلوك شخصي يعتمد
على ثلاثه اشياء في جانب التحفيز في جانب
القدره وفي جانب اسمه المحرك والمسبب
التحفيز واضح التحفيز رغبتي انا وحماسي
اني امارس سلوك محدد وطبعا في اشياء
مختلفه التحفيز ممكن يكون جاي من هويتي
انا انسان رياضي عشان كذا انا بمارس
الرياضه او يمكن التحفيز مرتبط بايش مرتبط
باني اخاف من عاقبه محدده انا اسو رياضه
لاني اخاف امرض فهذا يكون من ضمن التحفيز
لما نتكلم عن القدره القدره في جسديه وفي
ذهنيه الجسديه واضحه اللي هو ايش الحركه
الذهنيه تذكر مثال قائمه الطعام كان في
تحدي ذهني ليش انه يبغى له حسبه ما كل حد
ممكن يمارس هذه الحسبه بطريقه سلسه ايش هو
المسبب المحرك المسبب المحرك هو اشياء
موجوده في بيئتنا ممكن تشجعني اني امارس
سلوك محدد او ما امارس سلوك محدد ابسط
مثال اذا واحد مهتم بالرياضه عنده التحفيز
عنده القدره ايش المسبب يمكن وجود فقط
جهاز الرياضه في الصاله وانت داخل كذا
البيت وتشوف جهاز الرياضه اه لازم اتمرن
او يمكن يكون محرك لك انك تتحرك وتمارس
الرياضه هذا من ضمن الماذق اللي تساعدك
تفهم كيف الواحد يتخذ سلوك محله طبعا في
نماذج كثيره انا بختصر على نموذجين وننتقل
الى النموذج
الثاني النموذج الثاني اللي هو مبني على
شيء اسمه نظامي التفكير طبعا لما اتكلم عن
نظامين انا ما اقول ان العقل مقسم الى
قسمين انا اقول طريقه تفكير في تفكير بطيء
وفي تفكير سريع التفكير البطيء هو تستخدمه
لما تبذل جهد ذهني لما تحاول تحل مساله
رياضيه على او انك تقرا تقرير او تكتب
تقرير هذ غالها جهد
ذهني النظام السريع اللي هو ايش ان ما
تبدل فيه جهد على سب المثال انا قص اتحدث
هنا وفجاه حد ينادي اسمي على طول
انتبه لما اقود مركبه اقود سياره بعد فتره
خلاص انت ما تفكر لما تغير المقو وتحرك
الجير او تدوس بترول او تضرب بريك ما فيها
فكره اساسا وكثير منا خاصه انا بعد فتره
احس انا كيف وصلت هنا ليش كل شي صار مبر
قرارات خلينا نقول
اوتوماتيكيه انا اعطيكم مثال فقط انه ايش
الفرق بين النظام البطيء والنظام السريع
في الشريحه القادمه في سهم السهم على
اتجاه محدد وانا اريدكم تخبروني اتجاه
السهم مش بالحديث بالاشاره معى اخر اذا
السهم فوق تسوي كذا اذا تحتوي كذا اذا
يمين كذا اذا يسار كذا ورجاء لا تضربوا
الشخص اللي جنبكم طيب بسرعه بقدر الامكان
تاشر على اتجاه
السه
طيب في ناس في اتجاهات غريبه صارت طبعا كل
حد في
اتجاه ايش الفكره اللي صارت هنا ايش
الفكره في ناس شافوا السهم اتجاه اليمين
بس الكلمه تقوللك يسار نوعا ما ايش اللي
صار النظام السريع عندك على طول باغي
يجاوب متحمس النظام البطي يقول لحظه شويه
كان في شي غلط عشان ك في اشارات يمين يسار
في واحد سوى فوق هذا موضوع
اخر طيب ايش
المشكله ايش
المشكله التحدي الكبير اللي يصير معانا
انه خلال
اليوم 55% على الاقل في دراسات تقوللك
اعلى احنا نستخدم النظام السريع وسبحان
الله هذا في شي جيد ليش لانه هذا يقلل
عليك الجهد ما تبدل جد ذني كبير وبالتالي
يوفر عليك طاقه وايضا يكون في مصلحتك
ينقذك من مواقف انت في غنى عنها تخيل نفسك
انت في غابه هذا المثال دائما اعطيه تخيل
نفسك في غابه وتشوف اسد وين افضل انك تركض
و تقس تفكر والله الاسد ما جوعان او يمكن
تحول
نباتي مصلحتك طبعا انك على طول تتخذ قرار
وتركض بس في نفس الوقت هذا الفكر السريع
ايضا في مساو اللي هو ايش يمكن يخليك تتخذ
قرار ما في مصلحتك وهذا كثير يصير وين في
التسوق نشتري اشياء احنا ما نريدها تلفتنا
الاشكال والالوان وفلان اشترى وهذا اللي
ظاهر الحين وهذا اللي ماشي بس ما يكون
فعلا يلبي احتياجاتي بس اتخذ قرارات سريعه
عشان بس ارضي
نفسي فهذا المشكله مع او التحدي مع النظام
البطيء والنظام السريع طبعا هذه احدى طرق
التفكير احدى النماذج مثل ما ذكرت في
نماذج اخرى طيب الحين السؤال اللي يسال
نفسه طيب وبعدين خبرتنا ان التفكير معقد
وعطينا نماذج ايش ممكن نسوي اذا قدرنا
نستغل هذه النماذج او هذا الفهم انه
يساعدنا ان نسخر ان نخلي الافراد يتخذوا
قرارات افضل هنا المكسب الحقيقي اعطيكم
تطبيقات بس عشان توضح
الصوره التطبيق
الاول متعلق بقياده المركبات وهذه كانت
تجربه واقعيه في احدى الدول لاحظوا ان
كثير من الاشخاص لما يقودوا المركبه
ويوصلوا عند مخرج محدد يكونوا على سرعه
وبالتالي طبعا هذا في خطر الحواد وفي خطر
على حياه الانسان طبعا الادوات انك تغير
هذا السلوك كثيره منها مخففات السرعه على
سبيل المثال او الرادار او الاشياء
الثانيه لكن هنا كان حل جدا جميل استخدموا
فكره الخداع البصري ايش الخداع البصر اللي
هنا انك انت لما تسوق السياره وجنبك اشجار
او حتى خلنا نقول اعمده
كل ما المسافه بين العمود والثانيه او
الشقره والثانيه تكون ابعد ما تحس انك
تسرع بس لما يكون هذه الاشجار قريبه من
بعض يعطيك انطباع انك تتسارع
فيش التجربه انك لما تدخل المدخل هذه
ترتيب الاشجار والمسافه بين الاشجار تقل
تبدا مسافات بعيده بعدين تقل تقل تقل فاش
اللي يصير واحد مار في هذا الشارع يحس انه
كل ما يقترب يحس انه قاس يتسارع يعطيه
الانطباع انه فعلا يصير بسرعه كبيره
بالتالي يبدا يخفف السرعه طبعا كان في هدف
اخر اللي هو التشجير فهذا احدى النماذج او
احد الطرق اللي تساعدك انك تسخر هذا الفهم
انك تخلي الفرد يتخذ قرار
افضل المثال الثاني اللي هو الدارج كثير
اللي هو يلعب على المقارنه الاجتماعيه او
السلوكيات الاجتماعيه وهذا كان متعلق
باستهلاك الطاقه لما نتكلم عن استهلاك
الطاقه التحدي الاساسي في استهلاك الطاقه
ان كثير مننا ما يعرف ايش معنى 2000 كيلو
وط ايش معنى 2000 كيلو وط هل هذا برميل هل
هذا علبه هل هذا ايش بالضبط فكان لازم
نشوف حل كيف نقرب هذا المفهوم للفرد
المستهلك فكان احدى
التقارب اللي في هذا المجال انه كان توصل
الفاتوره للفرد لكل بيت والفاتوره فيها
شريحه قارن استهلاكه في الكهرباء مع
جيرانه او المنطقه او الحي اللي هو ساكن
فيها وكان الفكره الاساسيه هنا ايش انك
اول شيء تقرب مفهوم الاستهلاك لما اشوف
المقارنه ابدا افهم اه انا انا استهلاكي
كذا مقارنه بالمجتمع اللي انا فيه او الحي
اللي انا ساكن فيه بس الهدف الاكثر اللي
هو ايش انت تقارن استهلاكك هل هو فعلا
عالي او قليل في كثير من الاحيان لما
الواحد يشوف استهلاكه اكثر عن المجتمع او
الحي اللي فيه يحس نفسك يسوي شيء خطا
وبالتالي يبدا يقلل استهلاكه ايضا هذا
التطبيق مبني على فهم السلوك
البشري اخر مثال متعلق بكوفيد طبعا كان في
تحدي في
اللقاحات وكان احدى التجارب اللي كانت
تحاول تشجع الافراد اللي مهتمين باللقاح
انه يروحوا و ياخذوا اللقاح مبني على شيء
جدا بسيط كانت الفكره انه كل واحد يستلم
رساله نصيه فلان فلان فلاني تم حجز قرعتين
من اللقاح الك ولاحظوا اول ما توصل
الرساله لهذا الشخص يجي
ليش فيها كلمه سحريه
حجز عندنا في الطبيعه البشريه اي واحد
يسوي لنا خدمه احس اني لازم ارجع
للخدمه بالعماني يقوللك اتجمل فيه لازم
ارجع الخدمه مره ثانيه فايش اللي صار هنا
اول ما توصل الرساله ويقوللك تم حكس تحس
الله هذا راح وتعنى وراح وح قزلي الحس
لازم اروح
الحين مره ثانيه حل جدا بسيط غير مكلف
مبني على فهم السلوك البشري ايش الرساله
اللي اريد اوصلها هنا الرساله هنا بقدر
الامكان اذا قدرنا نفهم السلوك البشري
وعرفنا كيف نفكر ممكن نقدم حلول جذريه
فعلا للفرد
والمجتمع شكرا
[تصفيق]
جزيلا